scenes of Devastation abound in Florida
the morning after Hurricane Ian struck
land the full extent of the damage was
only beginning to come to light homes
flooded and on fire boats piled up like
children's toys people in cars
navigating their escape already the
governor is calling it an historic
weather event there's going to be a lot
more assessing that goes on in the days
ahead but I think we've never seen a
flood event like this we've never seen
storm surge of this magnitude and it hit
an area where there's a lot of people
and a lot of those low-lying areas and
it's going to end up doing extensive
damage to a lot of people's homes so
there's going to be a lot of work to do
and slammed into Florida's Gulf Coast
with Winds of up to 240 kilometers per
hour inundating communities in its path
the coastal city of Fort Myers was
overwhelmed with water
but the effects are being felt Inland as
well more than two million people lost
power during the height of the storm
rescue crews were unable to respond to
cries for help from those who didn't
heed evacuation orders that didn't stop
a local news reporter from helping a
woman trapped in her car she was on her
way to work in a hospital when she got
stuck it's believed others may not have
been so lucky but with roads and bridges
underwater it will take a while to fully
assess the damages to lives and property
the rain and flooding is expected to
continue as Ian moves North Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera